dann begrüßt sich herzlich bei bild live
den neuen nordrhein-westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten hendrik wüst schon
guten tag steht morgen das bild hat sich
bei den deutschen eingebrannt nach
diesem corona gipfeln da sitze im die
kanzlerin unternehmenssitz unter anderem
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
ist nicht mehr so jetzt sitzen sie da
plötzlich bei markus söder sozusagen wo
er bisher saß was macht das mit ihnen
und was macht das mit den deutschen
möglicherweise
was das mit den deutschen macht das
glaube ich wird man absehen können
abwarten müssen was das mit mir macht es
ist an spannend das ist ganz klar die
zeit ist herausfordernd die lage ist
dramatisch die menschen zu schützen die
gesundheit der menschen leib und leben
zu schützen ist unsere gemeinsame
verantwortung das ist ja ausdruck dieses
bildes der bund und die länder gemeinsam
und wir haben gestern sehr sehr
konzentriert gearbeitet möglichst gut in
und durch diesen winter zu kommen da
kamen dann dieses papier aus weil sie
hier auf dem tisch liegen habe sie
konnten auf jeden fall gestern schon mal
helfen in der pressekonferenz da war
nämlich an einer stelle unklarheit da
wusste die kanzlerin nicht genau wie ist
das jetzt da kam die frage nämlich nach
profifußballern zweig ob die sich jetzt
impfen lassen müssen wenn sie spielen
wollen kannst du dann wusste nicht so
ganz genau hat es dann irgendwie erklärt
40.13 wusste es schon gar nicht sie
konnten dann helfen also wie genau ist
jetzt die regelung am wochenende für die
bundesliga profi fußballer darf chemie
spielen ja oder nein wenn wir in den
stadien zweig machen also viele menschen
sich daran halten müssen entweder
geimpft oder gewesen zu sein dann finde
ich und das war einige meinung aller
ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten muss das auch für
diejenigen gelten die ja den meisten
körperkontakt da auf dem platz haben
denn ich für die profifußballer und da
haben wir das
bundesgesundheitsministerium jetzt
gebeten gemeinsam mit dem
bundesarbeitsministerium
die regeln zu schaffen dass das
durchsetzbar ist alles andere versteht
kein mensch also es gibt noch rechtliche
bedenken aber darauf sie das durch
kriegen so wie sie es wollen ja das muss
jetzt genau geprüft werden weil für die
einen auf der tribüne ist es freizeit
für die da unten ist es arbeit das macht
einen rechtlichen unterschied aber ich
finde da müssen wir drüber kommen also
sie wollen es genau so haben einheit
sozusagen zwischen fans und spielern das
ist da argument das ist das argument und
ich finde auch zu recht kann man vor
tragen die fußballer werden gut bezahlt
sind vorbilder auch für junge menschen
dass da der entscheidende punkt und ich
finde dann müssen sie sich auch benehmen
wie vorbilder bei friseuren zum beispiel
ist es genau anders da ist 3g am
arbeitsplatz aber für die kunden gilt
dann zweig auch in restaurants wird es
anders sein da ist 3g für die da
arbeiten aber zweig für die die
reinkommen also da geht auch nicht die
einheit wir haben das müssen wir uns
sehr genau anschauen friseure sind
körpernah dienstleistung hat dafür hat
es noch mal wieder abweichende regelung
gegeben das wird jetzt in der umsetzung
zu beachten seien aber es macht glaube
ich schon ein unterschied ob ich eine
kellnerinnen und kellner habe oder einen
gut bezahlten fußballer der auch
gesellschaft von dem vorbild ist von der
bezahlung vor vorbild charakter
möglicherweise war das argument war ja
auch ein
heimspiel einheitlichkeit aber vorbild
ist finde ich auch ein ganz wichtiges
thema wir haben doch gemerkt wenn alle
staatlichen ebenen gemeinsam agieren
gemeinsam kommunizieren wenn
testimonials wenn vorbilder mitmachen
dann funktioniert wenn alle
durcheinander laufen funktioniert es
nicht dann ist es kompliziert dann
versteht keiner was los ist und ich
finde von gut bezahlten vorbildern kann
man das erwarten dass sie damit machen
verstanden 3g am arbeitsplatz
beschäftigt jetzt natürlich viele gilt
dann ab montag wissen sie ist schon bei
sich in der staatskanzlei wie sie
kontrollieren wir haben ein testangebot
und das wird dann für all jene die sich
nicht haben impfen lassen verpflichtend
werden müssen die aber davon aus dass
diese sicher sein scheinen und
mitarbeiter dann in der staatskanzlei
des landes nordrhein-westfalen
vernünftig sind und sich haben impfen
lassen und dann muss ich davon aus die
kanzlerin hat dann offenbar auch ihnen
gestern ins gewissen geredet hat gesagt
da wird noch nicht genügend kontrolliert
es wird nicht genügend überprüft also
das gerne selber prüfers ist generell
bei allen dingen das ist am arbeitsplatz
wichtig es ist vor allen dingen in der
gastronomie wichtig das ist bei allen
veranstaltungen wo menschen
zusammenkommen
sie kontrollieren in der stadt und wir
können das in der staatskanzlei relativ
einfach machen an anderen stellen ist es
glaube ich komplizierter wir müssen mehr
kontrollieren stichproben kann nicht
bedeuten da ja jeder macht mal so wie er
spaß hat sondern es müssen regelmäßige
stichproben seien und dass jeder auch
die sorge haben muss ich werd erwischt
wenn ich mich daran halte wir haben in
nordrhein-westfalen verabredet dass wir
die bußgelder deutlich erhöhen
wenn ein wirt das schleifen lässt wenn
dann nicht kontrolliert wird vier bis zu
5000 euro es muss wehtun denn es ist
kein spaß mehr hier geht es um leben und
tod gilt das auch für busse und bahnen
bis zu 5000 euro wenn man da dann
ungeimpften getestet werden kölner u
bahn das waren jetzt die bußgelder für
diejenigen die überprüfen müssen und es
nicht tun an anderer stelle sind die
bußgelder auch erhöht werden erhöht
worden um schmerzhafte signale auch zu
setzen was ist danielle panabaker
ungefähr also zum beispiel jetzt kölner
u-bahn ich gehe da rein ab montag bin
dann theoretisch nicht geimpft nicht
getestet was da jetzt bis zu 1000 euro
seien auch da es muss wehtun im öpnv
stehen die leute dicht an dicht aber
auch da kommt es natürlich darauf an
dass ordentlich kontrolliert wird wir
machen das in nordrhein westfalen schon
seit vielen monaten neben steuergeld in
die hand um zusätzliche kontrolleure zu
schicken das soll jetzt auch bundesweit
passieren das wird ein riesen auf was
aber ist mit all ihren masken
kontrolliert ja jetzt wird es ja
wirklich konnte dieses jahr wieder gehen
sie morgens in die u bahn rhein fahren
sie vermutlich nicht jeden tag gar kein
vorwurf aber da ist es halt einfach voll
auch hier in berlin fahren sie in
neukölln mal s-bahn u-bahn morgens und
dann gehen sie in den waggon rein und
sagen zeigen sie mir ihren impfstatus
zeigen sie mir einen eher negativen test
es wird nicht es wird nicht
flächendeckend gehen es geht mit
stichproben aber die müssen so
regelmäßig sein dass niemand mehr
anfängt draufzusetzen nicht erwischt zu
werden es ist wie im straßenverkehr wir
werden auch nicht jeden tag kontrolliert
aber wir wissen es kann geblitzt werden
wir können kontrolliert werden die
strafen sind spürbar und deswegen halten
sich die allermeisten auch im
straßenverkehr an die regeln aber da
wird ja auch provoziert er wird schon
bewusst eingestiegen ohne maske und da
gehen jetzt kontrolleure rein die
brauchen ja auch gewissen schutz dafür
vermutlich ja so aufgeladen ist die
stimmung ja um dann zu sagen na jetzt
zeigen sie mir neben der maske auch noch
ihr testergebnis ja das sind ganz oft
teams von privaten sicherheitsfirmen
polizei ordnungsbehörden die dann
gemeinsam reingehen und so muss das auch
sein aber ist beißt die maus keinen
faden ab es muss regelmäßig kontrolliert
werden und die strafen müssen spürbar
sein gibt so viele fragezeichen hier
noch in sachen umsetzung in dem papier
ich klettere einmal durch es steht hier
zum beispiel bei punkt 3 da geht es um
die booster impfung
es sollen jetzt zunächst alle über 60
jährigen gezielt angeschrieben werden
schreiben sie schon und wo kriegen sie
die adressen her für die briefe die
adressen haben wir natürlich alles start
können wir auf die melderegister in
einer solch wichtigen frage zugreifen er
übersetzt würden sie das wissen sie das
wissen wir aus den melderegistern auch
sie wissen von jedem nordrhein westfalen
wie alter ist ja das wissen wir aus den
melderegistern ihren personalausweis
steht ihr geburtsdatum das sind die
daten die wir haben das ist das kleinere
problem karl josef laumann unserer
gesundheitsminister hat schon vor wochen
angefangen diese briefe zu schicken
jetzt eine über 70 jährigen erst gegen
die briefe raus an die über 60 jährigen
die große aufgabe wird nicht das
briefeschreiben sein sondern die
infrastruktur wieder auszubauen wir
müssen viele millionen menschen boostern
hinzu kommen immer noch viele menschen
die zum ersten und zum zweiten mal sich
impfen lassen jetzt noch die kinder
impfung da gibt es jetzt die zulassung
für die jugendlichen also da wird
richtig viel geändert werden müssen das
ist die zentrale herausforderung aller
staatlichen ebenen bund länder und
kommunen das umzusetzen da wurde er
gestern diese zahl von 27 millionen
genannt 27 millionen impfungen die zu
schaffen sein halten sie es realistisch
in welchem zeitraum das zu schaffen wir
haben im sommer an einigen tagen über
mir eine million menschen am tag geimpft
also wenn die maschinerie wieder richtig
hoch gelaufen ist packen wir das auch
aber das muss jetzt auch an also bis
jahresende das war die das war die
zielsetzung möglichst bis jahresende
diese zahlen zu erreichen ich weiß für
nordrhein westfalen sehr genau in
welcher woche an welchem tag wie viele
menschen geimpft werden müssen und jetzt
werden wir heute nach dem bundesrat der
ja gleich folgt werden wir gemeinsam mit
den kommunalen spitzenverbänden
nordrhein-westfalen besprechen wie wir
das umsetzen wie haben die erlasslage
schon verändert mehr beinfreiheit mehr
flexibilität für die kommunen
impfzentren aufzubauen im stationen
impfangebot dezentral aufzusetzen da hat
jeder alle freiheiten die er braucht um
das bestmöglich vor ort zu machen aber
klar ist wir müssen richtig gas geben
sie haben dass kinder impfen gerade
angesprochen die möglichkeit soll jetzt
geschaffen werden steht ja auch im
papier drin das dann im dezember auch
wirklich bei kleinen kindern bei den ab
sechsjährigen gm werden kann jetzt sind
sie selbst familienvater weiß ihre
tochter ist noch kleiner aber würden sie
ihre tochter ihren sohn mit 67 acht
jahren impfen lassen ja wenn eine
zulassung da ist würde ich das sofort
tun wir haben auch bei allen impfungen
lieber kleinkindern an stehen immer die
impfung
erfassten schweren es schon eine
abwägung macht man das für die
gesellschaft sozusagen impft man jetzt
die kleinsten für die gesellschaft
müssen die solidarisch sein tja das ist
eine interessante fragestellung ich
würde mein kind allein schon deshalb
immer impfen um selbst den maximalen
schutz für das kind zu haben selbst
schwache krankheitsverläufe möchte ich
bei meinem kind auch nicht haben also
sie empfehlen auch den eltern in
nordrhein westfalen in deutschland ihre
67 jährigen impfen zu lassen sie
erwarten dass auch von dem wenn es eine
zulassung gibt würde ich es immer
empfehlen das nimmt kinder arzt zu
besprechen auch in der abwägung mit dem
gesamten gesundheitszustand ich bin
jetzt hier nicht der oberarzt der nation
ich kann es niemandem sagen du musst
wenn ein kind andere krankheitsbilder
hat oder an risiken sind muss man das
immer genommen kinderarzt besprechen ich
persönlich kann nur sagen da unserer
tochter würde ich jede impfung nehmen
die zugelassenen wo die ärzte sagen dass
das sinn macht die letzten fragezeichen
hier aus dem papier die betreffen unter
anderem auch dem pflege bonus wie hoch
wird das müssen wir jetzt mal genau
anschauen das muss spürbar sein wir
haben gestern mit dem bund mit dem
bundesfinanzminister darum auch gerungen
es war unser anliegen dass ein signal
gesendet wird an die pflegekräfte ein
signale gesandt mehrheit also ab wann ab
wann würden sie sagen dass spürbar für
die die sich da abrackern die kein
weihnachts urlaub haben wer also jetzt
noch mehr arbeit kriegen weil sie die
pflegeschlüssel noch erweitert haben ja
wenn wir bei 500 euro sind glaube ich
ist es ist es ein signal das muss aber
schon sein das muss auch bei den
menschen ankommen die impfpflicht dort
auch in den krankenhäusern auch in den
alten hallen ab wann gilt die ab wann
können wir dann davon ausgehen dass
tatsächlich alle geimpft sind weil
impfen dauerte eine zeit erst zwei
kämpfe die verabredung haben wir gestern
getroffen die verabredung muss jetzt
umgesetzt werden der vielleicht künftige
kanzler zugesagt dass mit der ampel tun
zu wollen das muss schnell erfolgen
ich denke in den nächsten zwei wochen
muss das möglich sein da
gesetzesentwürfe auf den weg zu bringen
diese ganze operation impfen testen
vorsicht das duldet alles kann auch
schon also da dauert es aber offenbar
noch nicht noch ein bisschen weil man
eben noch nicht weißt wie man diese
impfen nicht so schnell umsetzen kann
kann man braucht ein gesetz dafür und
das muss geschrieben werden aber das
wird möglich sein und die
geschäftsführung der bundesregierung in
person angela merkel dazu gesagt der
vielleicht künftigen bundesregierung
also der ampel entwürfe zur verfügung zu
stellen das ist in dieser übergangszeit
völlig üblich dass sozusagen die
geschäftsführung die ausgehende
regierung als service für die künftige
arbeitet das muss jetzt auch
funktionieren das funktioniert als
service für die ampel das klingt gut
letzte frage letztes fragezeichen
nämlich thema lockdown wir lernen jetzt
heute morgen alle ganz deutschland lernt
hospitalisierung since it ends das ist
das neue wichtige wort lernt die
schwellenwerte auswendig 3 6 und 9 und
bei 9 ist es hier so schwammig
formuliert da gibt es dann weitere
maßnahmen nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz heißt sehr locker
und lockt das dann möglich hat 9 das
heißt die maßnahmen die im
infektionsschutzgesetz sind unter dem
vorbehalt dass an landtag zustimmt das
war ja der streit in den letzten tagen
deswegen ja die ganze streiterei auch im
bundestag bis hin zwischen den ländern
und dem bund aber werkzeugkasten sehr
klein ist das heißt in jedem fall
weitere maßnahmen bis hin zur schließung
von einrichtungen wir reden jetzt von
einer pandemie der ungeimpften wir
wollen keinen lockdown und deswegen ist
wichtig dass die verabredeten maßnahmen
jetzt eingehalten werden dass wir eine
solche situation verhindern wie es
weihnachten wie feiern wir weihnachten
eingeschlossen für uns oder gesellig ich
hoffe gesellig ich hoffe im kreis vieler
geimpfter menschen das hat jeder von uns
auch ein stück selber in der hand das
was wir jetzt verabredet haben ist ein
erstes paket das umgesetzt werden muss
in der hoffnung dass kein zweites und
drittes folgt also sie versprechen dass
wir nicht am 19 dezember bei den
nächsten mpk erst weihnachten abblasen
sozusagen zumindest ein geselliges
weihnachten und an den karneval in
dieser pandemie sind schon viel zu viele
versprechen im guten wissen und mit dem
guten wissensstand des tages gemacht
wurde nach ähnlichkeiten wollen wir
haben dieses paket verabredet um einen
lockout zu vermeiden
wir haben dieses paket jetzt zur
umsetzung und je schneller das umgesetzt
wird und je mehr menschen sich daran
halten um so besser und umso schöner
wird weihnachten werden danke an den
nordrhein westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten hendrik wüst für das
beseitigen einige fragezeichen und aber
auch zugeben dass es an der einen oder
an der stelle tatsächlich ein paar
fragezeichen gibt vielen dank herr wüst
gerne